So now that we can build an index, we'll want to use it.
We'll want to use it to respond to queries.
If you understood how the add to index code works,
I think you'll be able to write the query code yourself.
So the lookup procedure takes 2 inputs.
The first is an index, and that's the data structure we've been working with.
It's a list where each element
of the list is a list containing a keyword
and a list as its second element,
and that list is a list of URLs
where that keyword appears.
The second input is the keyword to lookup.
That's what we're searching for.
So the output of lookup should be a list
of all the URLs associated with the input keyword.
So as an example,
we constructed the index here
where we've added 2 URLs
with the keyword udacity.
The result from doing a lookup on the keyword udacity
should be a list containing those 2 URLs.
We should be concerned what happens if
the keyword does not exists.
If the keyword doesn't exists, well there are no
URLs associated with that keyword.
So we would just return an empty list.
So see if you can define the lookup procedure.